what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer for Netflix is whoo assassins
I saw eco Elias on the thumbnail for a
nose like yeah we're checking this out
we're checking this out - laughs eco
wise hey man uh what I could only assume
as a generic action movie plot with some
cool action right incredible action the
way it goes let's check it out
you have the power of the box your
strength goes to read them are you
don't just kill the head of the trash
he's your father
we have to whatever happens I got your
back
oh that's all
come on Hachi
mm-hm
to be in Jersey is [ __ ]
[Music]
I like it
[Music]
I might have been a little more excited
to see Mark Dacascos and Nico glass have
a fight see me gather although I think
if what this trailer is suggesting to me
is true it could be interesting to watch
the same fight scene spliced between two
guys like if ya really go down that
rabbit hole of like let's use creative
wipes to have Mark Dacascos in one part
of this track it's shot and then is oh
it's equal why isn't the next you know
yeah I mean that is cool that's gonna be
a cool little film experiment this is a
TV series I think this is a show this is
the new Iron Fist yeah that's a new wife
ray I mean they got the guy who was an
iron fist which is cool look out Louis
tan I think is his name and then you got
Ryu here Byron man oh yeah I've never
really had this big breaks in street
fights coming no after now it's coming
well I'm sure the fight scenes will be
cooling off I'm not gonna lie I'm not a
big fan of a lot of visual watch I'm
gonna watch this anymore of sin to Mark
Dacascos that was I mean that was played
for laughs with the weird face after but
yeah some of the fantasy CG and stuff
like that looks like it's stretching
maybe a little further than whatever
this shows budget is well it reminds me
of when I would watch like Jackie Chan
do the medallion or the tuxedo yeah like
gently and his fight scenes have never
been like oh the most 1,000% realism has
always been these wire effects usually
in play but even when he goes like full
fantasy and what was like prefer
especially when you associate naturally
Mark Dacascos and eco wise especially
with the most grounded realistic type of
brutal fight scene ever and then to have
this heightened fantasy element is
really just an adjustment period I I
feel like I'd have to go through because
I associate him so much with oh I'm
gonna watch like more of the night comes
for us a raid kind of deals well head
shot you know and that's the thing as
you mentioned the top of this reaction
groundbreaking action with a kind of
generic plotline I thought it was
interesting because it's like we're
seeing eco eyes in a different
environment than we're used to but
within that paradigm it's like oh yeah
you're the chosen one
parents and powers I shall see that
blahblah huh I know yeah so I was like
okay this seems like kind of a generic
action fantasy but with insane Marshall
or next in so instead of a superpower he
just I guess becomes a really gifted
martial artist yeah and I've said this
Siemens since the night comes for us
trailer that I don't think the trailers
for any film starring any one of these
amazing martial artists ever properly
communicates just how cool the fight
scenes are gonna be when I come for us
especially didn't even come close to
properly teasing just how groundbreaking
and crazy those fight scenes were not
only choreographed but shot who the
traitors do nothing to do that and the
same thing you know I'm watching some of
these fights in like I bet these fights
are gonna be so much cool yeah and they
cut these trailers a lot which always
kind of confuses me because I feel like
the action is one of the main stars
especially because we know these dudes
are so good at the physical action so I
was kind of wish they would let some of
these fights or a fight play out and
breathe a little bit because I feel like
that would pretty easily hook people and
the other thing I guess I'm now
wondering is like how eco wise American
or at least English language acting
career I wish yeah I was that to I was
like at first this felt like a foreign
film and I wasn't mugged a there are
they saving China they heard Chinatown
in the rap song what are they saving
Chinatown okay restore balance and San
Francisco
okay well I guess that makes sense why
they're speaking English I hope in some
of the fight scenes they're not speaking
he's not Chinese with you guys wide
variety of different types of ethnic
Asian backgrounds in Asian Chinese as
all I can confirm here you got that
white girl from Vikings in here that was
the most badass among them will speak a
mixture of their native language and
English just to show how world savvy
they are but also how sinister they're
you know I didn't know Mark Dacascos was
in this I still am a little bit let down
that we're not gonna actually see them
interacting with one another maybe
there'll be some scenes were they like
looking in the mirror Buddhism venom
thing yeah this is the same character
from John wick but just like talking to
him in his well that's the thing after
John wick 3 you're like man that Mark
Dacascos guy
great with his lines really really funny
he can do more than just be you know
bald intimidating badass give me a wheel
carries Ares dialogue-driven scenes yeah
and I want to see some of that in here
but it seems like they're just resorting
to Mark Dacascos cool bald dude yeah
totally
the idea of eco wise being in a martial
arts driven show sounds cool for this
fantasy element I'm not really gung-ho
for yeah it's one of those things where
I'm really worried this is gonna turn
out cheesy and also especially because
it's a ten episode series and not just a
movie in the back of my mind I have hope
because I generally like who's involved
and I am sure that they could have some
perfectly original ideas up their
sleeves for this yeah
but the problem is the most spectacular
thing about this trailer to me as
expected is the action yeah you know I
mean Mark Dacascos eco wise it's enough
to sell me on to know that they're in a
show together even Louis 10 that excites
me as well be at least enough to check
it out
Philly hasn't gotten to the big break he
deserves he's been on shows and whatnot
but he deserves to have a bigger
breakdown now we gotta get that guy from
Jurassic Park in here which guy you know
the guy who's always like I've got the
embryos and I'm getting away you know
the guy who's the scientist who's like
in every Jurassic Park movie is like the
only guy who always returns Henry Wu
yeah he should come in and join we
should just get all these guys to show
up it's tiny and imagine what he has to
Shane T put them in here too sure
because you know like that guy played
Ryu he hasn't had like his full-on big
huge like sure moment in the in the
middle spotlight so let's get all those
guys I feel like you're making a good
point that I will better understand once
I watch this video back probably naming
actors in a similar position of a
similar ethnic back I feel bad for eco
Elias was a a lot of the time these
great martial arts actors in their own
home countries make amazing
groundbreaking films and then they get
put in the most generic kind of things
in America it's a real bummer like
jelly's American films were honestly
those American filter or whatever Lethal
Weapon 4 okay the one I really loved it
was the movie one Unleashed Unleashed
yeah yeah with Morgan Hoskins yeah but
most of them are like just generic and
then there's like Tony Jaa who came over
here for the tiny my in it you're like
oh man come on I mean Mark Dacascos is
like the coolest things like John wick
done like no he's got a special role
there and he got to really shine but you
know Eko Elias was in that Mark Wahlberg
movie now he's in this weird camión
force awakens and like come on man give
him a real give him some subside you
know I'm being kind of harsh but the
effects are just so cheesy in here that
I'm like god this looks generic well
yeah and I go watch it for the fight
scenes but okay it makes it seem like
the crossing-over process is pretty hard
I don't know it makes it seem like it's
hard to cross over because then you're
like is this just all they're offering
you or is this your judgment yeah this
judgement why is it that the American
stuff we've seen you do is either slight
or very familiar and is only special cuz
of your actions yeah yeah yeah
all right guys well neither way are you
excited for whoo assassins I think
there's enough to at least give this a
shot I'll watch like the first five
minutes subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and now you
can check us on patreon we got plenty of
goodies over there see you guys